we have billion new users expected
online by 2017 there's a huge
opportunity to grow your business most
of these users will be in emerging
markets so you should consider how they
may differ from your current audience
here are 10 tips to help you get ready
speak your users language in your app
and on the Play Store
make sure your users understand your
content by localizing your app first
dates and times should be
internationalized and displayed
according to their phone settings for
many markets numeracy is higher than
literacy use fewer alerts and provide
graphical cues with audio and voice
support keep interactions simple avoid
scrolling menus and use topical
browsable interfaces for example
autocomplete and curated lists can be
better and searching and filtering
design your app for different languages
allowing for different sentence lengths
and structures the app translation
service available from the developer
console can help and remember to test
everything with native speakers deliver
the right content and features research
new markets thoroughly and build
features on local trends and preferences
for instance think mobile first don't
rely on familiarity with email and web
passwords offer phone number based
registration multi-sim phones are also
popular which you can detect since
android 5.1 in order to for example
adapt your apps data usage by sim
allow for slow and intermittent data
connections many users will not have
access to reliable data connections it's
important to adapt your app to use less
data and if possible to also work
offline try to separate UI from network
activities so users can pre cache
content over Wi-Fi optimize all images
and consider using web P it's smaller
and file size and alternatives for the
same image quality you can also give
users control over when and what
connection they use particularly for
large downloads or syncing accommodate
low end devices and smaller screens in
emerging markets many devices tend to
have small screens so make sure you
optimize your UI by testing on multiple
screen sizes
you should also adapt your app to
low-end devices which may have low
memory low processing power and low
resolution
ensure your apps will run on older
versions of Android to reach the next
billion users in emerging markets
consider backward compatibility to
jellybean and we're practical back to
Ice Cream Sandwich optimized for less
phone memory and shorter battery life
your users phone may have 512 megabytes
of internal memory or less so apps need
to be efficient with memory usage also
disk space is lower than developed
markets so keep your apk size under 10
megabytes optimize the contents of your
apk by using highly targeted images
mobile optimized libraries remove
redundant content and enable ProGuard to
out unused code also make sure your app
can run from SD card storage consume
only the data you need to in most
emerging markets users will pay for data
as they use it your apps initial
download each update and foreground and
background data all add cost balance the
benefits of an update with a cost to
your user of installing it consider less
frequent releases and balance the cost
of installing an update with the
benefits to your user avoid background
services where possible
reflect local buying habits and cycles
localize your prices and remember a
simple exchange rate conversion may not
be right a good onboarding flow is vital
to ensure maximum buyer conversion
provide app and subscription trials so
the user can try before they buy and
when planning promotions understand
local buying cycles link promotional
activity with holidays events and
monthly data plan refresh dates grow
your audience with app promotion when
you're ready to launch app install ads
can help you grow an audience and
universal app campaigns that you set up
straight from the developer console make
it easy your campaign is automatically
optimized to meet your CPA target by
finding the right balance on Google
search Google Play Google Display
Network and YouTube research the best
local marketing channels you can promote
your app on and leverage YouTube and
other popular social media sites in
target countries also try app invites a
smart way to grow your audience by
letting existing users invite their
Google contacts via email and SMS engage
and support your users locally don't
leave your users to work things out for
themselves start by reading and
responding to app reviews then go local
by creating user groups for countries or
languages through social media channels
build a core of power users and
encourage them with involvement in beta
tests and update plans and look for ways
to help them share their findings by
offering them access to your support
team or developers
for more information on building your
app for success in emerging markets read
our checklist in the distribute section
of the Android developer website if you
want more tips on how to grow your app
or game business check out the other
videos in this series and download the
secrets to app success on Google Play